welcome everyone to the fourth and final
lecture in this year's series of Terry
lecturers my name is Harold Attridge and
I'm the Dean of yell Divinity School
those of you who have been with us for
the last three lectures have been
treated to a comprehensive account of
the cosmos and our place in it we have
learned how truly vast both spatially
and temporally is this world of which we
are a small part we have learned how my
Newton precious in a sea of dark matter
and energy are the bits of Stardust from
which we are composed we've learned how
special is the time at which we live
when we are conscious enough to observe
the universe and when there's an
abundance of universe to observe we've
been reminded of the inconvenient truths
of our time of the perilous implications
of exponential growth for the future of
our planet as we have learned all this
we've been on a marvelous star trek
riding a visually stunning rollercoaster
taking us from galaxies far away and
long ago at the outer reaches of the
visible universe down to the strange and
quirky world of subatomic particles
we've seen galaxies explode danced a
tango through the cosmic void and
finally coalesce and what appears to be
cosmic harmony our guides on this
journey by now need no introduction we
have come to appreciate the enormous
learning and artistic creativity a
physicist Joel Premack and his lovely
wife and collaborator Nancy Abraham's
please join me in welcoming them for the
last of this year's Terry lectures
cosmic society but before I call them to
the podium let me please remind you to
turn off your cellphone's as I do mine
and in the Q&A session after the lecture
please come to the mics at both sides of
the hole please now join me in welcoming
back Joanne
thank you very much for that excellent
summary of everything we've said over
the last three lectures that was great
well welcome to the last of our lectures
cosmic society in the modern West and in
many other countries we have a gap in
our thinking that may never have existed
in human society before because we have
no shared cosmology no meaningful sense
of how we actually fit into the big
picture the countless complications of
daily life distract us so few of us ever
really stand back and notice that we
have no coherent context in which to
understand what we face together in the
third lecture we emphasize that humanity
is at a pivotal moment because we've
been going through an unprecedented
period of exponential growth not only of
our population but of our impact on the
planet humanity is running out of fresh
water and topsoil worldwide destroying
the forests decimating fish stocks and
many other species pouring carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases into
the atmosphere changing the climate and
in many other ways simultaneously
hitting the limits of exponential growth
we explained that the early universe
also hit the limit of exponential growth
in what is called cosmic inflation after
cosmic inflation the universe continued
to expand but far more slowly and this
transition could be the model for the
transition that we need to make to a
slow but sustainable period of growth in
this final lecture we want to look more
deeply into the potential role of a
meaningful cosmology in contributing to
the kind of thinking that might actually
allow this transition to happen in a
sane way dedicated people all over the
world are working on solutions to
individual global problems and they're
experimenting with new ideas and
technologies but even if there were a
brilliant
complete blueprint for renewing the
earth and building a sustainable vibrant
and just worldwide civilization it's
still unlikely that people today could
agree on implementing it a blueprint for
saving the earth fantastically useful as
that would be would not on its own
convince the world that success is
possible and therefore worth the cost
today what we need is a big vision a big
new way of thinking which if enough of
us shared it would encourage us to act
together we need to feel and know in our
bones that something much bigger is
going on than our petty quarrels and our
obsession with acquiring material things
and that the role we each play in it
defines the real meaning and purpose of
our lives lots of people religious and
non-religious into of this but they
can't agree on what the big picture is
or what it demands of us because their
individual views have no framework in
which to contemplate the global size
scale of our problems but we are all
playing a potentially cosmic role
whether we know it or not the great
mythologist Joseph Campbell in his last
book the inner reaches of outer space
argued passionately that what the modern
world needs more than anything else is a
story that unifies us he wrote the old
gods are dead or dying and people
everywhere are searching asking what is
the new mythology to be the mythology of
this unified earth as of one harmonious
being we humans are crossing right now
from tens of thousands of years of
imaginative origin myths to the origin
myths that future generations will
accept and live by which will not only
be verified by science but largely
inspired by science a variety of people
from scriptural literalists to corporate
polluters to post modern philosophers
denounce or dismiss science but if they
ever take a modern medicine or fly on
jet they're trusting their
lives to science and that's actually a
much better indication of what they
believe then their sound bites are some
groups will always cling to old
ideologies but science is now a
worldwide collaboration and its
discoveries are available to everyone
the new cosmology is the only possible
foundation for a globally unifying story
of ourselves it would not impose a
single way of thinking on everyone's
lives however humans are endlessly
diverse and this is our great strength
remember that as illustrated by the
cosmic or Boris on different size scales
different laws control events what this
suggests here is that we can preserve
diversity on the scale of humanity's
local lifestyles while finding consensus
on the encompassing scales of the planet
and the cosmos no one in an age of
computers and other electronics based on
quantum mechanics and global positioning
systems based on general relativity can
seriously argue that there's no reality
beyond the visible but how do we get a
handle on the whole thing and how could
that help us cosmologies came into
existence to do that a cosmology is a
language of metaphors and images that
lets its believers feel they have a
handle on reality beyond the visible and
helps them find inspiration in it every
cosmology includes an origin story which
explains our place in time in this final
lecture we are returning to a
fundamental problem that was raised in
the first lecture that in the high
places of human consciousness where
cosmic mythologies took our ancestors a
narrative darkness and shrouds our
bright lives people who have no
believable origin story for themselves
rarely realize what they're missing
let's look at this on a more local level
the origin story of our nation the
Boston Tea Party the ride of Paul Revere
the Declaration of Independence
the Revolutionary War the Constitution
the Bill of Rights the brilliance of our
founding fathers all of these are
elements of the American mythology that
binds our citizens together in a shared
venture of upholding freedom and
democracy although none of us were
actually there to witness any of these
things even our name the United States
of America tells a story in the same way
but on a much larger scale to bind a
global community together in the shared
venture of preserving and protecting the
conditions for our children and
grandchildren to thrive on this
spectacular planet we humans need to see
that the through line of our species
back beyond our earliest ancestors and
back through the preceding cosmic events
is everyone's origin story this story
explains how we intelligent beings fit
into the universe and how deep and
ancient and identity we share with each
other we are part of a phenomenally rare
and cosmically important event the
emergence of intelligence and
civilization in a universe that was once
nothing but particles and energy in the
beginning is the way origin stories
traditionally open but now the phrase in
the beginning must be followed by of and
then something a beginning is not
something that exists in itself it's a
way people think about what exists it's
a way of drawing a line we can say in
the beginning of Earth or in the
beginning of the visible universe but in
the beginning of everything is not a
clear notion until you can define
everything which you can't do if you
don't have a convincing origin story so
what is the do origin story for our
visible universe let's construct it
backwards the way that science
discovered in so in the beginning of the
20th century most astronomers still
believe that the Milky Way was the
universe this slide shows the Milky Way
is mapped by the great astronomer
William Herschel
with the Sun as we now know incorrectly
located in the middle astronomers
observe blurry objects that were called
nebulae Latin first effort clouds that
is they were interpreted to be clouds of
gas but Edwin Hubble discovered in 1924
that some of the nebulae are actually
galaxies far beyond the Milky Way
suddenly the universe became in calculus
and our galaxy just one among many then
in 1929 Hubble made an even more
stunning discovery the distant galaxies
are all moving away from us and the
farther away they are the faster they're
moving Hubble had discovered the
expansion of the universe this had
actually been predicted by Alexander
Friedman and George limit using
Einstein's general theory of relativity
although einstein himself resisted it
and reasoning backwards there had to
have been a time when everything was
together now called the Big Bang but
there was no direct evidence for that
yet in the mid 20th century there was a
lively debate in astronomy between the
steady-state theory and the Big Bang the
steady-state proponents argued that the
universe is basically unchanging in time
with matter constantly appearing to form
new galaxies as the old ones expanded
apart the steady-state theory was
seriously undermined by the discovery in
1965 of the heat radiation of the Big
Bang and also the discovery that very
distant galaxies aren't like nearby ones
this showed that the universe has
actually been evolving since the Big
Bang we explained in lecture two that
since the discovery of the accelerating
expansion of the universe in 1998 all
the evidence supports one cosmological
theory which is technically known as
lambda CDM but i think the double dark
theory is a better name for it in this
theory galaxies and groups and clusters
of galaxies are formed and held together
by dark matter while these
gravitationally bound structures are
being accelerated apart by dark energy
so it's those two components dark matter
and dark energy that are the basis of
the double dark theory
cosmology is an historical science like
geology and evolutionary biology these
Sciences attempt not only to understand
the way the universe the earth and
living systems work but also the actual
historical paths that led to the present
it is sometimes claimed that because the
actual past was unique the historical
Sciences provide a lower grade of
knowledge than the laboratory sciences
like physics and chemistry in which the
effects of changing conditions can be
explored by experiments this claim that
the historical sciences are inferior is
especially popular with people who
prefer biblical or other traditional
accounts of our origins it's also
popular with post modern thinkers but
this is a serious misunderstanding
experimental historical Sciences both
make predictions about new knowledge
whether from experiments or from the
past the experimental Sciences predict
that is the theories they're predict new
knowledge that will be discovered
through experiments in the historical
sciences the predictions are about new
knowledge that will be discovered about
the past as Lucretia said our age cannot
look back to earlier things except where
reasoning reveals their traces and of
course the reasoning is embodied in the
natural laws in the historical sciences
new knowledge is constantly produced as
new areas are explored by new techniques
let's look at the record of cosmology as
an example so here are four major
predictions and their confirmations
there's the expanding universe
represented by the proportionality of
distance and velocity this is actual
data and as I said this was discovered
by Hubble and it had been predicted
based on general relativity the heat
radiation of the Big Bang which we call
the cosmic back ray at background
radiation the existence and in fact
a pretty good estimate of the
temperature was predicted by George
gamma off and his collaborators in the
40s and it was discovered as i mentioned
in 1965 the thermal spectrum that's
represented by this curve where the
error bars have actually been
exaggerated by two orders of magnitude
the actual errors are smaller than the
line so this shows that really is
thermal radiation and that had been
predicted by applying thermodynamics to
the standard theory of the universe the
fluctuations in the cosmic background
radiation were first discovered by the
cosmic background radiation the cosmic
background Explorer satellite and that
was also the source of this data and
John Mather and George Smoot shared the
Nobel Prize a few years ago for these
great discoveries the prediction was
made by my colleagues in me based on the
cold dark matter theory and cold dark
matter combined with dark energy
predicted also the details of the cosmic
background radiation that have been
discovered by more recent experiments
including the Wilkinson microwave
anisotropy probe if you apply nuclear
physics to the Big Bang you can predict
the evolution of the light elements
during the first three or actually more
like 10 minutes and this was done
especially by Bob Wagner in 1967 and
David tytler and others and the w map
Wilkinson microwave anisotropy probe
have confirmed this in detail and the
double dark Theory also predicted the
large-scale distribution of galaxies and
clusters and so on and this has been
confirmed in great detail by the big
mapping projects so the thing that you
should remember from this is that
there's a continuing pattern of
prediction and confirmation in cosmology
and that's why cuz modern cosmology is a
mature science and why we can have great
confidence in it now that leads to the
question what led to the Big Bang our
best understanding is that it began in a
moment of exponential growth called
cosmic inflation
and in the lecture yesterday we
discussed that but let me briefly remind
you what would become our present
visible universe began as what we might
call a spark point a region only a
little bigger than the Planck scale
which was the tip of the Serpent's tail
in the cosmic aura Boris right up there
so it's just a little bigger than that
in a mere 10 to the minus 32 seconds or
so of cosmic inflation that spark point
inflated exponentially by at least 30
orders of magnitude to the size of a
newborn baby that is from the tip of the
tail halfway around to the human scale
cosmic inflation set up the initial
conditions for the Big Bang and spawned
all the quantum impulses that have
shaped the cosmic web and will continue
to do so effectively forever then
suddenly the baby universe went through
a phase transition called the Big Bang
and the rate of expansion dropped from
exponential to slow and steady and from
then to now the present the observable
universe has expanded around the cut the
rest of the cosmic hora Boris and grown
to the size of the present-day cosmic
horizon this science is the basis of a
new origin story the story will no doubt
go through many revisions both an
emphasis and accuracy but this is the
first cosmological story we've ever had
that is supported by a tremendous amount
of solid evidence so let's think of this
as an origin story in the beginning of
the Big Bang was cosmic inflation
space-time came out of the Big Bang
smoother than the smoothest lake but not
perfectly smooth it had wrinkles perhaps
as small as elementary particles
wrinkles as big as the universe and
wrinkles of every size in between this
was good for us because if the universe
had come out perfectly smooth in the
beginning it would still be smooth now
only much expanded and there would be no
concentrations of matter no galaxies no
stars no planets no life it has been the
imperfections in the universe the
primeval wrinkles
that have been the blueprint of our
universe and developed into all the big
structures from galaxies to groups of
galaxies to clusters and superclusters
when cosmic inflation ended space-time
was filled with a hot dense incredibly
smooth and non turbulent expanding fog
of particles including quarks electrons
neutrinos and dark matter particles all
free and unbound as the universe
expanded and cooled the particles
swiftly revealed their distinctive
nature's annihilating interacting fusing
or in the case of dark matter only
gravitating light from the Big Bang was
so intense it hammered the electrically
charged particles the early universe
expanded at the same rate everywhere
about 400,000 years later the fog broke
the universe became transparent and the
light of the Big Bang streamed in all
directions carrying images of the infant
universe at that moment these images
would be decipherable by intelligent
life-forms that might evolve billions of
years in the future and learn to
intercept this light meanwhile Dark
Matter everywhere kept moving sluggishly
toward the wrinkles in space pulling
atoms along great concentrations of dark
matter collapsed because of their
gravity into invisible halos and deep
inside them clouds of hydrogen gas began
falling together to form the first stars
the burning stars produced the rainbow
of other chemical elements and the
energy that would be on later make life
possible on planets that did not yet
exist gravity has been fighting against
expansion since the Big Bang and in
denser regions gravity has won and
created stable structures like galaxies
and groups and clusters of galaxies
these are bound together gravitationally
and will travel together forever as a
unit in the great expansion inside these
structures protected by their dark
matter from the violin
of dark energy gravity has tamed the
space here planets slowly evolved
potentially into homes for intelligent
life but on large scales where space is
wild expansion is already winning wild
space and it's dark energy keep
increasing while the amount of dark
matter stays the same about 5 billion
years ago the balance of power on the
large scale shifted from dark matter to
dark energy and the expansion of the
universe stopped slowing down and began
to accelerate what gravity has not
already consolidated it never will by
coincidence at that moment of balance in
the switch over between the two great
forces of the universe our solar system
formed in the suburbs of the Milky Way
no sooner had earth begun to cool then
it acquired microbial life stars like
the Sun live 10 billion years or so and
by the midpoint of its lifetime which is
now the microbes on earth have evolved
into a race of creatures with the
intelligence and technology to discover
the universe decode its history in the
still arriving light of the Big Bang and
begin to appreciate their awesome place
in the cosmos but with the same
intelligence and different technology
this complicated species has also
overrun the planet and despoiled much of
its surface including the oceans while
scarcely understanding the implications
of what it has been doing because among
other reasons it has not yet learned to
think in large enough terms sadly our
own country is almost at the bottom of
the heap of all these countries in
accepting the theory of evolution
because of a combination of widespread
religious fundamentalism and the
politicization of science our species is
now at a turning point in a struggle
between the despoliation of the world
and a big new perspective but unlike the
power struggle between dark matter and
dark energy the victor here will not be
determined by the laws of physics alone
an accurate cosmology could help us rien
vision the world if this rien visioning
is done with intelligence and empathy it
could shift the balance of power to the
new perspective and energize our
creativity while minimizing and
eventually d legitimizing the forces of
despoliation our new origin story tells
us that our ancestors are not just our
grandparents and great-grandparents not
just our ethnic group not just the human
species not even just life or even earth
but stars galaxies Dark Matter all the
forces of nature living and not in an
unbroken chain back to the Big Bang the
origin story that Nancy just told began
at a point called cosmic inflation but
the inevitable question always arises so
what came before that as I mentioned
earlier there's a certain distance back
in time that we can explain with the
double dark theory including cosmic
inflation but that's the end of the line
for now the instant of cosmic inflation
is the current border between the
physical and the metaphysical to
describe the likely source of cosmic
inflation we have only theoretical
speculations are they about the real
universe we don't yet know but
understanding that we're at this point
stepping out of science into metaphysics
we can ask well what did cause the
cosmic inflation that opens our origin
story it turns out that when we
extrapolate the equations back to find
the origin of cosmic inflation the most
likely possibility is that inflation is
eternal let me put this in a bigger
context so many ancient myths said that
the world was created in the midst of
primeval chaos in this modern picture
that I'm about to present the Big Bang
began with an extremely brief explosive
expansion called cosmic inflation in the
midst of a primeval chaos often called
eternal inflation
the theory of eternal inflation says
that there are two possible states of
being space-time our familiar picture
and eternal inflation the realm of
eternal inflation is also sometimes
known as the super-universe or the
multiverse or the meta universe
according to the theory once the state
of being exists it goes on forever
although tiny pockets are bubbles form
in it which become big bangs that evolve
into universes our own universe would
then be a bubble of space-time in
eternal inflation eternal inflation is
hot and dense and the expansion of the
space between bubble speeds up
exponentially in this next slide we
represent eternal inflation by what we
call the cosmic Las Vegas that's this
top half up here where the laws of
chance rule so the laws are in this
metaphorical picture coins constantly
flip heads means the coin doubles in
size and there are two of them tails
means the coin shrinks to half its size
consider a coin that's had a run of
tails it becomes so small it can pass
through the grating on the floor and
when it does it's dark energy changes
into ordinary energy at the instant it
passes through the floor it exits
eternity time begins with the big bang
and a universe starts evolving this
collection of different universes is
called the multiverse and there's no
causal connection between them at least
not most of the time and the fact that
we represent them as snowflake like
things but with different shapes is
supposed to indicate that the laws of
physics could very well be different in
these different universes well here's a
different way of representing cosmic
eternal inflation rather an animated
visualization that we've made just for
this lecture you will see many universes
coming into existence and expanding
within eternal inflation let me first
show show you some stills
so what we're about to see may be the
first video that tries to convey an
intuitive sense of eternal inflation
although it can't be taken literally
there's this set of arrows in the middle
representing three dimensions it's there
for orientation the universe's may first
seem all to flow toward the camera but
as the camera moves around which you'll
see by the changing orientation and size
of that center of coordinates you'll
realize that the universe's are actually
streaming equally in all directions we
have to use so many visual conventions
to portray anything in video like having
the light appear to come from a source
in a specific direction and having
things that recede into the distance
appear to get dimmer but these
conventions are used to pull us viewers
into the video several times during the
video you will see bubbles that form so
close together bubble universes that
they've collided before they could move
apart until very recently we thought
there was no way to test the theory of
eternal inflation but it's just been
realized that if our bubble is like one
of these with a collision in its past
astronomers may be able to see the
effects of the collision by a careful
study of the cosmic background radiation
especially using observations by the new
satellite that's just gone into
operation called the Planck satellite or
by careful studies of the motions of
distant galaxies when you see the video
you'll notice that some bubble universes
expand and at the same time see
mysteriously to fade out there are two
examples these universes are actually
moving away from us at the same time as
they're expanding which looks very weird
well enough of this explanation let's
look at the video
so you can see some of them that are
getting dimmer as they grow larger those
are the ones that are moving away there
was one there that one came toward us
notice that we're moving away now from
the center of coordinates
so what we've done is to actually
represent the equations that describe
this model of eternal inflation using
the same program that Pixar for example
uses to do animations but it's it's a
true representation of the equations and
by studying it we're actually learning
interesting things
there's another bubble collision
so maybe our own universe was one such
bubble maybe that one our entire
universe the region created by our Big
Bang is a rare jewel a tiny pocket in
the heart of eternal inflation where by
chance inflation stopped time began and
space opened up for things to happen and
complexity to grow where did eternal
inflation come from well although we can
and do concoct theories about this it
may be that we cannot know because such
events if they can be called that can be
lost in principle in quantum uncertainty
knowledge depends on the preservation of
information in a pure quantum regime
nothing persists knowledge would not
exist we can't even imagine how we could
find out about a beginning of quantum
uncertainty if that's even a meaningful
phrase now you may wonder if this theory
of eternal inflation and the multiverse
has any conceivable relevance to
everyday life well the Dilbert cartoon
suggests that it might
so although the lawyer guy is fired
would you lawyer guys take over origin
stories have traditionally been told
from the beginning to the end or from
the beginning to the present but that is
no longer the only possible way origin
stories of the future may also start
with the present and move both forward
and backward just as the cosmic spheres
of time move outward as the past zooms
away from us at the speed of light and
the future flows toward us from the
center outward is the way that science
learns about the past first the nearby
past we see nearby galaxies as they were
only a few million years ago then as
instruments improve and we could see
farther out into space we see further
back in time observing distant galaxies
as they were billions of years ago and
this lets us expand our story rather
than trying to imagine the very
beginning which may be a meaningless
phrase we can think of the beginning as
being just as unknown as the distant
future and ourselves as explorers moving
outward from the center creation stories
around the world mainly fall into three
categories depending on their view of
time one the world is cyclical in other
words it continually changes in the
short term but in the long term the
cycle itself is unchanging to the world
is linear it's always changing and time
goes in one direction or three the world
is unchanging although if created it
went through changes in a distant
irretrievable past these are the basic
forms of origin stories it turns out
that all three of these modes of
storytelling are part of our new story
because each applies on a different size
scale on the size scales of earth for
which humans have intuition the seasons
are cyclical and so are the births and
deaths of generations of people
the movements of the planets the return
of comets on the size scale of the Big
Bang though and of cosmic evolution the
universe is changing in one direction
it's expanding faster and faster and we
have no reason to think that it would
ever contract but if the theory of
eternal inflation is right then on that
grandest of size scales the meta
universe is in fact unchanging because
possibilities burst endlessly from every
quantum sized region yet on the whole
nothing changes the larger the past that
our minds encompass the larger the
future that we are capable of taking
seriously creating and protecting
because people see from the center a
tiny consciousness of history will be
mirrored in a tiny consciousness of the
future and the end result is a tiny
consciousness unable to grasp let alone
appreciate most of reality many people
who think the earth is only a few
thousand years old have no compulsion
against ending it shortly for some this
symmetric sort of closure actually gives
the whole thing meaning look at the 65
million copies sold of the Left Behind
novels which are a series about the
rapture when earth and people like Joel
and me will be violently destroyed while
the saved watch from heaven presumably
with satisfaction this kind of thinking
has no place in a cosmic society a
single human life may seem a brief
candle on the cosmic time scale but each
one of us embodies our entire species
evolutionary past and potential future
to achieve a very long-term future we
now realize that controlling and
surviving the power of our own high
technology is the hump to get over we
are facing this hump right now if we
humans don't make it the universe has
time to try and evolve intelligence
again but humanity will be Slough doff
as if we had never been
this powerful painting of the deluge
which is actually right across the
street at the Yale British art museum
portrays destruction on what was
considered at the time the cosmic scale
seems to me a kind of warning a reminder
that human existence is fragile but that
moral action may preserve us today
however we need not only moral action
but actions grounded in science a cosmic
society could be the ark that can carry
all of us of every color and kind
through the transition from despoliation
to cosmic perspective and to the safer
shore of a stable long-term civilization
building that arc now maybe what it
takes to assure the future of
intelligence in the visible universe
some people oppose the idea of space
travel because they fear that if our
human or more likely humanoid
descendants have the chance they will
run amuck and wreck the galaxy the way
that European conquerors wreck to so
many cultures that they colonized but
there's really no need to worry about
that because space pioneering would be
impossible for the short-sighted
egocentric kind of people we are today
to explore and gradually move out into
the galaxy as a project that could
really only be successfully undertaken
by a long-lived global civilization with
a shared unifying cosmology that
accurately reflects the universe a
civilization stable enough to welcome
home space travelers even generations
after they left so the good news is that
probably the only kind of creatures that
could successfully pioneer the galaxy
are the ones that should maybe this is
why no aliens are here they may have the
technology but not the mythology maybe
intelligence of the kind that develops
mathematics and high technology is
relatively common throughout the
universe but what is vanishingly rare is
creative intelligence of a deeply
artistic and philosophical
that conceptualizes its place in the
cosmos as accurately as it can that
seeks harmony rather than self
aggrandizement and develops imagery that
sweeps its members up imaginatively and
lets them experience their cosmos ever
more vividly through daring but accurate
metaphor this kind of intelligence is
what created the mythologies that bind
religions and nations together but no
such mythology yet exists that combined
our species together despite religions
and nations the kind of cosmology that
would make it possible in the long term
to explore the galaxy is the same kind
that in the next few decades could help
us solve the problems that threaten our
civilization and possibly also our
survival we need a meaningful cosmology
not only for the long term but for today
this is what could get us over but
cosmic hump figuring out in practice how
to create this science based living
cosmology should be a goal of everyone
who cares what intelligence could
accomplish if it gets to have a
long-term future as we said in lecture 1
each of us humans is practically an
entire aura Boris with a role to play on
each of these size scales we are so
diverse that the way to deal with global
problems is not to impose global
solutions but to cultivate the common
ground of a large-scale goal based on
principles and encourage small scale
decentralized solutions appropriate to
different situations created by
different kinds of people but all
inspired by the same goal or vision Rene
Du Bois the French American
microbiologist and ecologists who coined
the phrase been globally act locally
pointed out that as more public
activities and experiences become
globalized the counter trend of
identifying with a chosen neighborhood
or community what he called local
patriotism will increase since people
seek the comfort of small scale
communities and this is exactly as it
should be
we must learn to think on multiple size
scales although not all at once that's
too hard and probably ineffective our
newly discovered identities at these
different size scales must encompass not
overthrow each other we can in this way
let our roles on different size scales
and rich and expand us a common universe
can provide common ground scientists
science should be the foundation on
which we build our sense of reality but
the crucial relevant concepts of science
must be made understandable to everyone
non scientists as well and scientists
should avoid scientism they must never
claimed that science is all we need so
this is what Nancy and I have been
trying to do by presenting cosmology
through fundamental principles visually
expressed at the end of these lectures
let me summarize some of the points
we've tried to make we live at the
center of our cosmic spheres of time
just as all observers do this the finite
speed of light makes this inevitable
we're made of the rarest stuff in the
universe the heavy elements Stardust we
live in the middle of all possible sizes
in Midgard where the possibility of
tremendous variety and complexity coming
in small packages like us keeps life
interesting life of our complexity could
bloom nowhere else on the cosmic aura
Boris we live in a universe that may be
a rare bubble of space-time in the
eternal super universe outside our
isolated bubble which we call our Big
Bang there is neither space nor time as
we know them but here inside there's
time for evolution and history and their
space across which connections conform
and structures can develop we live at
the midpoint of time which is the peak
moment in the entire evolution of the
universe for astronomical observations
asian the most distant galaxies which
we've just acquired the technological
ability to see are beginning to
disappear over the cosmic horizon now
that the one slowing expansion of the
universe has begun instead to accelerate
we live at the midpoint in the life of
our planet it formed along with the Sun
and the other planets about four and a
half billion years ago it has about six
billion years to go before it is roasted
when our son swells into a red giant
star complex life evolved about half a
billion years ago and has about half a
billion years to go until the warming
Sun over heats the earth or billions of
years if our descendants move the earth
farther from the Sun and I explained in
a previous lecture how that could be
done from the point of view of our
species today is late enough to have
evolved to our present abilities while
early enough to have a multi-billion
year potential future it is late enough
that we're sobering up to the scale of
our problems but not so late that we've
lost all chance to solve them this is a
very special time that will never come
again our species is at a pivotal point
and time is of the essence we need to
crack open our imaginations we have
unlimited imagination but we're not
using most of it we are so bound by the
reward structures of our professions and
the peer pressure of this irony tinged
short attention span culture but there's
no need to reinvent the wheel the use of
imagery metaphor and story to make
people feel part of their universe has
been known for thousands of years it's
only the universe that has changed if
taken literally not only earlier
cosmologies but our new scientific
cosmology is completely misleading there
was no loud bang at the Big Bang and it
wasn't big there was no size to compare
it to language was invented to describe
earthly things and experiences and can
only be metaphorical when applied to the
universe as a whole so let's accept this
and not try to pretend in some misguided
attempt to defend science that
metaphorical descriptions are somehow
unscientific
the metaphorical nature of science is
not some dirty little secret but an
opportunity for creativity not only in
science but in the thought processes of
a whole culture we must get handles on
these cosmological concepts or they will
never serve us today's children could be
the first generation ever raised in the
universe they actually live in don't
teach them silliness like this and don't
teach them that the universe is so vast
and we are so tiny that's not true
either we're in the middle of all
possible sizes childhood is when most
people acquire the picture of the
universe they will carry in their
intuition all their lives we have an
obligation to teach children the real
story as early as possible and a
surprisingly easy thing to teach
children as young as eight or nine is
the powers of ten it's easier than
fractions and far more exciting to them
Joel and I have done this in elementary
schools and seeing how fast children
catch on we may soon if funding comes
through be working with public school
teachers to prepare short films to teach
cosmology to middle school students and
high school students global warming
extinction of species and other problems
that we discussed in lecture three can
be terrifying to children since they
sense and rightly so that the mess is
being left to them it's our job to give
them a realistic sense of empowerment
since the alternatives to Powerman are
so often cynicism or despair we must
teach them how far to believe and when
to maintain skepticism and this requires
that they understand the role of
evidence cosmic education would teach
children to function intuitively in the
real universe to believe in the real
universe not just memorize facts and
stick them on their brains like post-it
notes while nothing changes on the
inside cosmic perspective is partly a
matter of knowledge and partly a choice
of outlook
romantics are made of Stardust but
cynics are made of the nuclear waste of
dead stars both views are equally
scientifically accurate but if you were
a child which one would you rather learn
in fact why should anyone fight to save
humanity if they've decided were nothing
but nuclear waste a new cosmology has
the power to overturn the fundamental
institutions of society this is what
happened in the last cosmological
revolution on the scale of this one on
the Copernican newtonian cosmology
overthrew the medieval cosmology of the
heavenly spheres that revolution
undercut the rigid social and religious
hierarchies of medieval society that had
been partially justified by their
picture of the heavens and soon the
Divine Right of Kings was challenged and
the kings of England and France lost not
only their thrones but their heads this
is the kind of practical consequence
that can result from a change in
cosmology it's crucial not to abuse the
power of cosmology our friend the
astrophysicist and popular writer
Lawrence Krauss and others have argued
for example that we live in the worst of
all possible universes their reasoning
starts from the possibility that I've
explained that in tens of billions of
years dark energy will inflate the space
between our galaxy and all the distant
galaxies so much and so much faster than
the speed of light that the distant
galaxies will all disappear from the
visible part of the universe Krauss
concludes that since our own galaxy will
be left cosmically alone this is the
worst of all possible universes this is
a self-defeating reaction to our new
scientific knowledge and it's not called
for by any scientific evidence the truth
is that in the disk that the distant
future is unknown like the distant past
and it's self sabotaging to let our
emotions and attitudes toward life in
the 21st century be dampened by such
outrageously distant speculations
permanent changes are inevitable in an
evolving universe
and in this case it's the nature of the
dark energy which we don't really
understand yet that's going to determine
the distant future rather than feeling
sorry for our very distant descendants
and judging our entire universe today
based on what it might or might not be
like for them we need to appreciate our
cosmically central place and the huge
power of the universe is entrusted to us
to affect the distant future to focus on
our time and extend it as far as
knowledge lets us rather than concluding
that this is the worst of all possible
universes we should realize that if we
have protected and nurtured earth and
not destroyed our descendants chances to
have a wonderful life on it and to
eventually expand beyond it then we
humans us with all our flaws could be
the beginning of the whole future of
intelligence and what could ultimately
be the entire visible universe we humans
and our planet are Stardust evolving
into awesome complexity over billions of
years in an expanding universe shaped by
dark matter and dark energy it's now
possible to re-envision reality and
truly want to be part of the whole story
and live fully and responsibly in
cosmological time but it's not possible
for anyone to do this alone reality is
communal a person who is confident of a
reality that no one else sees is
considered insane reality has to be a
social consensus a cosmic society would
anchor the social consensus in the
truest universe of our time and thus the
cosmic society needs a group of willing
humans from anywhere and any background
on the planet to start this crucial
creative work a group that could also be
called the cosmic society since most
people will remain in denial as long as
the society around them lets them this
is an age for heroism for people willing
to start believing the evidence that we
are at the center of a new universe and
to act accordingly yes it's a strange
universe at first but this is our
home and people will inevitably get used
to it but hopefully soon enough to reap
its benefits while there is still time
to write the mistakes we made in our
earlier ignorance both non scientists
and scientists need to wake up and see
that as a community develops that
recognizes the new universe and strives
to understand its meaning for the 21st
century the techniques that all earlier
cultures used to share and develop their
cosmologies language imagery story
ritual mystical experience and other
artistic expressions will all be
essential without them cosmology will be
incomprehensible beyond a narrow circle
of experts and so such techniques will
flourish in a cosmic society the meaning
of life is determined by how we think
about it what is the meaning of life to
earth earth is after all the one that's
had to deal with all of it well we
humans are the ones who have to
articulate this for the earth because
we're the only ones who can we are the
thinking part of Earth to do so we have
to think on Earth's scale and until we
discover aliens capable of sharing the
mind of the universe thinking on the
cosmic scale is our job to as the
intelligence of the universe we have a
responsibility larger even than our
responsibility to earth having a
responsibility to the universe doesn't
mean we have to actually do anything
directly for the larger universe since
there really isn't anything we can do on
that scale but it expands the meaning of
what we human beings are here and now
when we push our imagination in these
ways and consciously step outside our
individual viewpoints into our larger
roles as the consciousness of Earth and
the cosmos we are bringing our mental
world into harmony with the double dark
universe we're learning to encompass
multiple size scales we're retraining
our intuitions and helping to create a
cosmic society
in 1633 the church in a rearguard effort
to uphold the medieval cosmology of
earth as the unmoving center of the
universe use the threat of torture to
force Galileo to publicly recant his
teaching that earth moves but even as
they sentenced him to life imprisonment
in his home Galileo is said to have
muttered under his breath at puta SI
muove a it still moves in the same way
people today in a rearguard effort to
uphold an obsolete cosmology may mock or
deny that we are cosmic phenomena living
at a cosmically pivotal moment but we
still are mockery and denial don't
change scientific facts the power of our
technologies is already propagating
through cosmological time affecting our
species and many others in the long term
cosmological time is what we are part of
whether we believe it or not political
decisions no one pays much attention to
today can silently prune out entire
worlds that might have been on every
size scale from depriving a single child
of an education to wiping out
intelligence in the galaxy cosmological
time may at first seem hard to imagine
or ridiculously abstract but it's as
real as anything can be and we need huge
imagination to figure out how to present
it to each other accurate alive
expanding our consciousness captivating
the young so that our culture will begin
to think in it and begin to see its
influence could the idea of a cosmic
society end up being a religion I will
flatly say no it's to free thinking it's
more of an ethic it requires faith not
despite the evidence but in the evidence
and in the possibilities that that
evidence suggests for our species it
allows us the shared experience of
actually belonging to the cosmos that
the evidence tells us exists above all
it allows us a way to elevate our
thinking to what our times demand can we
do it
you can't know what is possible or
impossible until you know what universe
you're living in here is a hypothetical
fragment of an origin story from the
distant future everyone in the universe
came from one little planet called Earth
the co-operative genius of a small group
of ancient earthlings made them rebelled
against the lemming like march to death
the majority were on to use up the earth
with no plan for the future it was the
acquisition in the early 21st century of
the ability to see into the cosmically
distant past and thus project far into
the future that allowed the rebels to
grasp the meaning of their own evolution
from the first available scientifically
cosmic perspective the rebels saw the
implications of what a few scientists
were already suggesting but had not yet
fully appreciated that intelligent
beings on planet earth were cosmically
central living at a pivotal moment in
time and had a potential destiny as vast
as the cosmic past if they would only
protect it this awakening led to the
great conversion from short-term
fragmented identities to the first
serious long-term species identity those
early rebels changed the course of
history and led to the Galactic
community of our time let's keep this
story possible we have a game-changing
opportunity right now we can have a
cosmic society right here on this
beautiful planet if we try as a
community to bring the universe home in
our thinking to earth
so in this final video we're going to
try to sum up some of the things that we
not only told you but also shown you
you
thank you all very much
you